Yeah.
>> What's up, man?
>> Jesus is not God
>> and he can never be God.
>> Why not?
>> Jesus Christ is just a human being like
me.
>> All right. You going to give me some
proof?
>> There's nothing special about Jesus.
What did it do so special that you
should call him God or a son of God?
>> Are you a Muslim?
>> Just Just say two things 100%.
>> I can tell. I can tell. I can tell. I
can tell you're a Muslim.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I am.
>> So, you said there's nothing special
about Jesus.
>> Yeah. Just one, not two. Something that
he did.
>> I got you.
>> Other people didn't do.
>> All right. He's the word of Allah,
right? Did you Is anybody else
identified as the word of Allah?
>> What?
>> Man, you guys you you guys are weird,
man. Like, what is up with this
religion, guys? You guys Your demons are
all in you guys.
>> If it makes you shaking, then
full of demons.
>> You're always shaking.
>> You're right. Get off my stage. You
demon man. Look at this religion, dude.
You can't make this up. Seriously, you
guys are helping. You guys are helping
us expose Islam to the best of the
ability, man. Doing a great job. Keep it
up, guys. Keep showing how unstable and
idiotic Islam is and makes you. How you
doing?
>> Good. Good. How are you?
>> I'm pretty good, man. I'm pretty good.
What's your thoughts on the topic?
>> Hopefully, you're not like the the past
two guests we had, bro. Hopefully,
you're a normal person.
>> There's no point cussing each other. It
does nothing. Um,
>> agreed.
>> What's it called? Is it a true when when
Jesus in John 17:3 when he says uh that
the father is the only true God? Is that
a true statement?
>> Yes.
>> Is Jesus the father?
>> No.
>> How many only true gods do you believe
in?
>> Well, as the as the statement is,
there's only one true God. Um, the one
true God is just multi-personal. In that
statement, Jesus is highlighting the
father, not at negation of himself or
the spirit.
>> Isn't the word only uh meaning
exclusive?
>> Well, depend. Well, yes, but it depends
on what in the sentence the word only is
talking about. So, like for example, you
would have a you would have a point if
Jesus said only the father is the true
God, but he doesn't. He says the father
is the only true God. Meaning that there
are no other gods, right? There's one
divine essence and he's identifying the
father with that. That doesn't negate
him also being true God as well, sharing
that same essence. So, like if I were to
say um 2 + 2 only equals 4, does that
mean that there are no other equations
that also equal four?
>> No, there are other equations.
>> Yeah. If I say 2 + 2 only equals 4, does
that negate other equations that also
equal four?
>> No.
>> Right. Um but if I were to change where
the word only is in the sentence, let's
say I put it in front of the equation. I
said only 2 + 2 equals 4. Then now am I
negating the other equations?
>> Yeah.
>> Yep. So right here the same thing
applies. Jesus doesn't say only the
father is the true God which would
negate him and the spirit and any other
persons being identified as true god.
But he says that the father is the only
true god. So meaning that the father is
the you know has the essence as the true
god. That doesn't negate the other
persons that also share in that same
essence as true god.
>> Yeah. Uh but we don't claim that there's
no other way to get to say that there's
uh how do I say this? There's no other
way to or another formula to get to
four.
>> Yes, there is. There's many.
>> No, no. I'm saying but we don't uh how
do I say this? We don't claim that there
isn't Oh, I'm sorry that Yeah, I
misspoke. That there isn't another way
to get to four.
>> I I agree. And Jesus doesn't claim that
no other person other than the father is
is the true God. So I I agree with you,
bro.
>> No, no. What I'm saying is if you only
believe in one true God, right, there's
only one.
>> Yep.
>> And he's saying that person is the
father. He's saying for example,
>> he's saying one of the persons is the
father.
>> Yeah. So for for example, we're using an
equation, right? Um only true God equals
the father. You agree with that
statement?
>> No.
>> You don't agree the only true God equals
the father?
>> No.
>> Why not?
>> Because in what you're trying to do,
you're trying to make us that only the
father is the true God, which is not
what Jesus says.
>> Then what does he say? He says it just
like how I said it with 2 plus two. 2
plus two only equals four. The father is
the only true god. Right? So that's what
we're talking about. It's not an
indigation of the other person's.
>> If I say you're the only one on screen,
can you say there's someone else on
screen?
>> If I say you're the only one on the
screen, is that a true statement?
>> It you can say that, but that's not what
is being said here with Jesus. That's
what I'm saying.
>> Yeah. I'm saying prove it.
>> Okay. So I just did. If I say 2+ 2 only
equals 4, does that negate the other
equations? Yes or no?
>> No, it doesn't.
>> Okay, but I said only though. So why
doesn't it why doesn't it negate the
other equations?
>> Cuz in mathematics, you can find another
way to get two or four.
>> No, we're not talking about the actual
reality. Why does that statement I'm
talking about the grammar, the
statement? Why does this statement not
negate other equations? When I say 2 + 2
only equals 4, why doesn't that negate
the other equations? Yeah, that's what
I'm saying. Because you can get to to
four in other ways.
>> I don't think you understand what I'm
asking. I'm not asking if you can get to
four in other ways. I'm asking if the
statement itself negates the other ways
you can get to four. Do you understand
what I'm saying?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I get I get what you're
saying.
>> Okay. Why doesn't the statement itself
negate other ways to get to four?
>> Why doesn't the statement itself prove
that you can get to that you can get to
four? Why doesn't the statement itself
negate, deny, reject other ways that you
can get to four? The statement itself,
>> I'm not sure. I'm not sure the answer
they look for. My answer, like what's
coming to mind is that I'm saying that
there's other ways to get to four.
That's why
>> what does that have to do with the
statement? That has nothing to do with
the statement itself. You get what I'm
saying? 2 + 2 only equals 4 is an
individual statement. Do we agree with
that?
>> Okay.
>> Does this statement itself negate other
ways to get to four? Does it deny that
there are other ways to get to four
within the statement?
>> Within the statement? No.
>> Why not?
>> Because you're saying this way you can
get to four. It has nothing to do with
other ways.
>> Exactly. I'm saying this way you can get
to four. And 2 + 2 only is uh equals
four. It doesn't equal anything else.
Right. There's no other answer to 2 + 2.
The only answer to that is four. That
has nothing to do with other equations.
We're specifically talking about
highlighting 2 plus two. Make sense?
>> Yeah. But I think that only works if
you're speaking to things uh more than
one.
>> If I'm speaking of what?
>> If you're speaking about things that are
more than one, but in our case,
>> we're speak we're speaking about
equations. There are more than one
equations, right?
>> Yeah. I'm saying the result. Right. Cuz
you're saying 2 plus 2 equals four,
right?
>> Yes. There's other equations to get to
four, right?
>> Yeah. But in our case, we're speaking
about one,
>> right? I'm only highlighting one of
those equations. That doesn't mean that
I negate the others.
>> I'm saying one as a result, but the
formula is like um cuz we believe in
only one true God, right? Not four gods,
right?
>> What does that have? I'm I'm trying to
see where this connects.
>> Your example is for something more than
one. I'm speaking about something that
is one.
>> I still don't understand.
>> Well, how do I say this? That's why I
was trying to give you the example of
only you are on screen. Is that a true
statement?
>> What does that have to do? How does that
connect with the 2 plus two state? Like
I'm trying to understand how that's how
that's not analogous.
>> Cuz I'm telling you, if you're dealing
with one, if I say, how can you get to
one?
>> No. No. In a formula.
>> No, no, no, no. I need What? This what I
need you to do. You're trying to tell me
that the example that I gave you is not
analogous. How is it not?
>> Because we the result is not four. For
us, the result is one.
>> We're not talking about the result.
We're talking about the grammar, the
statement on whether the statement using
the word only negates other things that
comes to the same conclusion. That's all
we're talking about.
>> No. No. Okay. So, when you say 2 plus
two only equals four. Okay. Okay. You
give me the answer cuz I know you want
you wanted the answer from me, but you
give me the answer why um that doesn't
negate other ways.
>> But you already told me the statement
itself is only highlighting the that
that particular equation has nothing to
do with other equations. Yeah, but I'm
saying how do I
>> The word only is modifying the answer.
>> The two go ahead.
>> Yeah, the word the word only is
modifying the answer. It's not modifying
the equation. The equation is 2 plus 2,
right? The word only modifies the answer
to that equation. Equals 4. Only equals
4, right?
>> That doesn't mean that there's not other
equations that also equal four. That
statement itself doesn't deny that. It's
just highlighting 2 + 2 equals 4 and
nothing else. It doesn't equal anything
else, only equals four. Make sense?
>> Okay. But what I'm saying, okay, for for
example, an equal sign both for an equal
sign, both sides, right? An equal sign,
both sides.
>> What What are you doing? What are you
doing?
>> Can I speak?
>> No, no. I I need to know what you're I
need to know what you're doing. Did you
understand?
>> Like what what's my point? What's my
point? Tell me what my point is. I feel
like I feel like you're wasting my time.
What's my point?
>> Well, I'm wasting your time. We're about
to see. Can you tell me what my point
is? If you can't If you can't explain
what my point is, then I'm going to go
ahead and move on. What's my point?
>> No, then you can just move on. I mean, I
was trying
>> No, no, tell me what. Tell I want to see
cuz I want to see. What is my point?
>> Yeah. Your point is just that that the
father is not the only true God cuz God
the only true God can be uh
multi-personal and you're using all
these formulas and things like that.
>> What is my point with using the
equation? What is my point with the ex
with the analogy?
The point of the analogy is that you can
get to um how do I say this? You can get
to uh the result in many ways. That's
what that's what you're doing.
>> I appreciate you for coming, brother.
Take take care. Let's bring up somebody
who can probably engage honestly. And
about to spend 20 minutes on this. You
got to be that dishonest in order to try
to play dumb to to keep a to to I don't
know what I I don't I don't even know
what the purpose is. Like what is the
purpose of that? Like for real. Maybe
it's a Hey guys, let's sign up to see
how how long can we waste Avery's time.
How long can we waste Avery's time?
>> Hello.
>> How you doing?
>> Oh, I'm fine. How are you?
>> I'm pretty good. Thank you.
>> Thank you for giving me the chance to
speak to you.
>> Of course, it's my pleasure.
>> So, um I had one question.
>> Um
what do you think or what do you
believe? Are there other per are or
whether other uh perfect human beings
except of Jesus?
>> No.
>> No perfect human being?
>> Nope.
>> Not even Adam before he sinned.
>> Before he sinned. Sure. But then he
sinned. So he was not perfect.
>> What is perfect?
>> Being sinless.
>> H
>> being sinless.
>> Is does God use Is this the definition
of God? How he how he defines perfect
human beings?
>> What
>> is this the definition of God? How he
describes a perfect human being?
>> Are you saying to be humanless.
>> Are you saying that this is this how God
described it? Is that what you're
asking?
>> Yes. Yes. Exactly. Sorry for my English.
>> No. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. To be
perfect.
>> What is the word for sinless?
>> For being sinless.
>> What do you mean?
>> Being perfect. Sorry. What is the word
for being perfect?
>> What do you What do you mean what is the
word for being perfect? Cuz you're
saying the word.
>> I mean, we are talking of course about
the Bible. So, uh the Bible
>> the word is just perfect, brother. You
just used it. It's perfect.
>> Okay. So um I will ask them the
question. We have Genesis 17 first one
uh first one where God speaks to Abraham
and he orders him to be perfect.
>> He says I am God Almighty. Walk before
me and be blameless not perfect. Be
blameless that I may make my covenant
between me and you and multiply you
greatly.
>> Okay. So you you know which word the
Bible uses here? I'm trying to see what
the correlation is with this and Jesus.
>> I mean the I mean the translation says
blameless but the Hebrew says tamim
tamim means perfect. I mean the word is
elsewhere used in the Bible several
times in the Old Testament for example
for God's word. God's words are tamim.
Tamim means perfect. I mean God's word
can't be cannot be blameless but they
can be perfect. So why is God telling
Abraham to be tam which is also used in
Arabic use it all?
We use it in Arabic as well
>> to be means to be complete whole or
perfect blameless or without blemish can
be literally or figuratively morally. So
to be morally um complete
>> have integrity question is very simple.
I'm not a big scholar, but my simp my
question is very simple.
>> Was God says he was him?
>> Wait, just really quick. Was Abraham
blameless
>> according to your God? Yes. I'm just
looking at the Bible, not at my
judgment. God says he's perfect. He's
perfect.
>> Just really quick, brother. We see that
God tells him to walk before me and be
blameless. He tell he commands him to do
that, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Did Abraham succeed in that? Was he
blameless? So, so you say God commanded
him to be somebody which he couldn't be
because why wasn't he blameless? Because
>> I didn't ask that. You're not answering
the question.
>> Sorry.
>> Did Abraham succeed in being blameless,
being perfect?
>> Yes.
>> Do you remember the story where Abraham
after being called by
>> I know I know which uh sorry for
interrupting you. I know which example
you are bringing. You are bringing for
example example to that it is his sister
but it wasn't his sister. It was his
cousin and his wife. So it was his wife
which was also his cousin.
>> Yeah. Putting putting putting Sarah in
danger and whatnot. So
>> yes.
>> So he was not perfect. He he lied a
couple times, didn't he?
>> So you mean that was this was this
before uh Genesis 17 or was it after
that? Actually I'm not sure but
>> I don't remember but it doesn't matter.
>> Me neither. Okay. But so okay okay okay
let's assume God said here we have a
command. Let's assume God didn't
wouldn't say be blameless but you are
you are if you would have used that this
one would this make more sense then to
my to my to my statement
>> he told him to be blameless he didn't
say you are blameless he said be
blameless
>> yeah so if he would have said you are
blameless you would be satisfied with my
point of view or the point I'm making
this is my question
>> then you would have probably had a
better argument I guess using Abraham
>> okay then look at look at Genesis 6:9
for Noah he uses the same word and now
It's not a command. It's a description.
>> What does he say? What does he say?
>> Shall I read it? I mean, my English is
not better than yours, of course.
>> It's okay. I I'll read it. What' you
say? Genesis 6.
>> 6:9.
>> He said, "These are the gener um these
are the generations of Noah. Noah was a
righteous man, blameless in his
generation. Noah walked with God." Okay.
Was Noah completely blameless in his
entire life?
>> God God says so.
I'm looking at what God is.
>> This isn't God speaking. This is Moses.
>> So you don't believe that the Bible is
God speaking. God inspired word.
>> Yeah. Inspired. Inspired. Sure. But not
everything is like the verbatim word of
God. Inspired by him, sure.
>> But not verbatim. There there are parts
of the Bible that's verbatim and there's
parts that aren't. So just question
here. Was Noah was Noah blameless in his
entire life. I mean, if if your Bible
says this or you or you're telling me
that the Bible is making another
>> but it doesn't it doesn't say this.
>> What doesn't it not what does it not
say?
>> Uh didn't Noah get drunk after the flood
>> according to your Bible probably. Yes.
>> Yes. So he was not sinless. Correct.
>> Is being drunk a sin according to
according to to the law of that time?
No. According to the there was no at
that time.
>> There is no such thing as being drunk
ever being okay.
>> What? But I mean look there is at that
time you did not have a law. God says
he's blame blameless. Now you you are
talking through a law which appeared at
the time of Moses.
>> Let's say it's
this is even Moses telling you about
this. There's never a time where being
drunk is not a sin bro.
>> So you so you say that if you get drunk
it's a sin according to Christianity.
>> According to the Bible.
>> Okay. So this means this statement is a
false statement. Just my question then.
No, it's not a false statement because
there's a difference between being
blameless in your generation and being
sinless your whole life. Nobody can
point to Noah, point the finger at him,
right? Out of all those people that he
was with, they can't um claim that he
was unrighteous. Not until he got drunk.
So, he wasn't sinless, bro.
>> So, I have I have another suggestion for
for you. I mean, this is an of course an
interpretation you have giving me now of
the word which is stating which is
stated there. Yes, I would give you
another one. I don't I think we spend
enough time on this. What is your
objection to Jesus being God?
>> My objection to Jesus being God. I mean
do you like I mean so now you are
changing the topic? Yes. From the
>> Do you see Do you see my topic?
>> Yes, of course. I I saw it.
>> Okay. So I didn't I I indulged you and
allowed you to take us off on something
else.
>> I dealt with your objection or argument
which didn't get us anywhere. It wasn't
even like there was no point to it. So
now bringing us back to the topic where
we can actually talk about something
that we know maybe we can actually get
somewhere with something that that
matters.
>> I mean what do maybe my question would
then be what is what do you think is the
um
the mightiest argument or the best
argument um for him being God according
to the Bible or according to your point
of view? Outside of explicitly calling
him God, I think that the strongest
argument is where it demonstrates that
Jesus is uncreated and that that through
him all things came into existence. So
meaning that he has always existed and
only only God is the one who always
exists.
>> So you mean because you always existed,
he is God.
>> That is absolutely right. You you would
agree with that, right?
>> God,
>> you would agree with that, right? that
the one who has always ex existed never
came into existence that that is God
alone right
>> yes I would say this is um and which and
which exists I would add which exists
eternally as well
>> yeah that's what that means
>> pre-existed into eternity
>> yep yep never coming into existence you
always existed you have eternally
existed that is God alone that's what
the Bible says that Jesus is that Jesus
>> has always existed that he is the
beginning and in the end, the first and
the last, the alpha and the omega, and
that through him all things came into
existence.
>> So this is your uh mightiest argument.
>> That's the mightiest argument.
>> Okay. Um I mean this is why I didn't
start with this question because I think
I mean there are several verses which
you would say are in support of uh Jesus
divinity and I would pick some of I
would say it's my opinion they are not.
But I I would have just one question
because um I mean you will often get
this question Jesus never said himself I
am God but you have of course
indications which would you would say
here he is actually saying this in an in
another expression. So actually he's
saying he's God but he's not direct
saying it. Yes. So my question would be
was Moses God?
>> So it sounds like to me that you're
moving away from the reason why I said
that Jesus is God and you're not
addressing that. And you want to go to
something else?
>> No, not not entirely. My my point is
just
>> Okay.
>> So, can you somebody
can you deal with what I what I said on
why Jesus is God that the Bible says
that he's the alpha and omega, the
beginning and the end and he's never
came he's he never there wasn't a point
where he came into existence but he has
always eternally existed.
>> Can you engage with that please?
>> Okay, I could engage with that. Of
course, I'm not a big scholar, but I
think my argument would be you have and
I don't remember the verse, but in
Isaiah, you have a verse where you have
a similar statement to G to related to
Yziah. I mean, you are the better one
who who knows the Bible. You probably
know which words I mean.
>> Isaiah 9:6
>> where it says about sorry
>> where it says a son is born, a child is
given, and his name should be called the
wonderful counselor, mighty God,
everlasting father.
>> No, no, no. It's quite it's in the
beginning of Isaiah and there it I mean
if you want me I can look up for it.
>> Yeah, try to look for it
>> just a moment then because I'm of course
not prepared for this one. Just a
second.
>> All right. Yeah, the typing always gets
me, man.
>> Bona, I think you were eating.
>> Yes. Thank you. All right. Well,
>> while you look for that, I'm going to
I'm going to read some chats from the
audience.
>> Yeah, of course. Of course. Sorry. I I
will I'm going through this.
>> All right. Sama says, "Hi from South
Africa. Glad to have you back. God
bless." Thank you. Thank you. Good to be
back. Verse. And again says, "Where does
how do we reach these kids?" Get that
verse. And the Allah gave me faith song
come from. How do we reach these kids?
Comes from South Park. Little Cartman
kept saying that. Get diverse comes from
Gino Jennings. I'm doing an
impersonation of Gino Jennings where
he's debating a trinitarian and he's
like, "Get the verse. Get the verse,
son. I just want Bible. Get the verse."
And the Allah gave me faith song came
from a Muslim that is acquainted with
life. Life uh he and life know each
other and that Muslim does music and he
made that song. So, yep, that's the
history behind those things. Joe Ban
says, "Thank you so much for your
ministry. has helped me so much when
spreading the word to a family member.
What advice would you have? Um I I would
just ask see a lot of this stuff guys is
just asking questions, gathering
information, gathering data on the
person that you're that you're talking
to and uh so that you know how to
communicate with that person. So I would
say ask them what do they believe? What
happens when you know what do they
believe? What happens when you die?
That's a great question to ask them to
gauge where their beliefs fall and then
you can, you know, deal with that from
there and lead them to the gospel and
what the Bible says and, you know, stuff
like that. So, just ask questions. Why
do you believe this? Where'd you get
this from? What are your thoughts on
this? Those type of questions help.
Okay. All right. Kevin says, "What's up,
man?" What up, Kevin? What up, man? This
right here is my PBS says, "A man
worried about another man's appearance.
He basically wants you to be more
attractive for him." # sus. Yeah, these
trolls. These Muslim trolls out here,
man. Na says, "Why Momo like that, man?"
Avery Cole, love y'all. Traveling Don
says, "Cheflogic was serving farmtot on
that tick tock hunt. Booked my table
reservation for the next dollar dinner
service." Lol. That's good. text Texas
toast says debate style idea. You you
each get to ban an argument such as
their response can't be the Bible is
false because it contradicts the Quran.
They pick one or two. Okay. So, pick a
particular argument that we ban and they
have to argue without using that
argument.
Glazio says, "What program/ website do
you use recommend for word study? Also,
if you granted corruption of previous
scriptures, then that would mean Quran
has expired verses and is not timeless
word of God." I would say, well, there's
there's a lot that you can use. Logos.
Logos I hear is pretty good. Uh, Bible
Hub is pretty simple and pretty good as
well, but I don't I don't think it's not
as as extensive as um as uh Logos. Uh,
Blue Letter Bible is pretty good. And
there's another one that I can't think
of right now. It's pretty good. Much
love and appreciation from South Africa.
Man, South Africa giving a lot of love,
man. JJ says, "They love playing games,
lol." Yes, they do. Timothy says, "God
bless you, Avery. Hope to see you in
Riverside, California soon. You've
gotten me into apologetics two years
ago. My hunger for the word is
insatiable, man. Praise God for that.
That's awesome. Ty the Fly Guy says,
"Avery, since when have you been
teaching middle school grammar?" My
goodness. Since I became a shake, man.
Since I became a shake, that's when I
began to to teach middle school grammar.
Jeez. So, Jer apologetics in the house
says, "Hey, Avery. Ignore this if this
feels like a self shout out. You gave me
the push to start my apologetics
channel. Tik Tok won't let me go live
without 500 followers. Any tips? Thanks
for all you do. God bless. Yeah. Uh just
make videos, make content, make good
videos and content, you know. Um try to
make clips that are no longer than 3
minutes and you push that stuff out,
you'll get a you you'll grow on TikTok.
It's it's easy to grow on Tik Tok, bro.
We got Mcho says, "Bro, I'm having a
debate. Trinity and Taled. Where do I go
to destroy Tawhed? I have some good
arguments like yours yesterday. Any
ideas? You're a G, bro. I'm always
saying big dog. Now,
um, answering Islam, go to Answering
Islam. Those articles dealing with are
amazing. So, go check those articles
out. It'll give you breakdowns, sources,
and everything like that. And, uh,
you'll be ready, bro. All right. Muslim
student is back. So I didn't want to
interrupt interrupt you. So I was
actually finished earlier than this but
I think you are reading now I didn't
want to interrupt. So I you are the
host. So
>> I should show politeness. So um it would
be sorry it wasn't
I had the another uh words in my mind.
It was Jeremiah I think uh 15.
>> Okay bro. Um Jeremiah just talk uh God
just says that he formed him in the womb
and he knew him before he formed him.
That's cuz God is all knowing and it's
for knowledge. Not because Jeremiah
existed.
>> I mean, this is of course your
interpretation interpretation. You can
say
>> that's what it says, bro. I don't have
to interpret. That's what it says.
Before you were in the womb, before I
formed you in the womb, I knew you
because God is all knowing, right?
>> Yes.
>> So, he knows he knows us before we even
exist, right?
>> Yes. So, does it mean that um because
God knew him, he was somehow existent?
Because God knew him before.
>> What? What? What? What did I just say,
my brother? What did I just say? What
did I just say? What did I just say?
>> You just said that he knew him before he
was born. So, he was not born. He was
not existent and God knew he we I'll say
I'll say this again and uh if you if you
if you're not going to be able to engage
with this, then I'm going to move on.
>> Yes, no problem. All right.
>> He knew him before he created him. God
is all knowing.
>> Yes.
>> So, he knows us before he creates us. Do
you agree with that?
>> Yes. Because he's all knowing.
>> Exactly. So, that's it. Jeremiah was is
a created being. God is all knowing. So
he knew him before he created Jeremiah.
Simple.
>> But I mean,
>> well, there's a but wait, what is what
is that? What is the argue here? There's
a but you you agree with me. What's the
butt?
>> Is it is it to like Huh? How can I still
make this maybe there's some way I can
make this into an argument? Is that what
like what this is?
>> No, no, no, no. This this is not what I
am saying. I mean,
>> so so can we move on to
>> I mean what would be the Okay. I mean I
didn't I don't want to waste your time.
So I will just bring one uh statement to
this and then
>> I appreciate that. So Jesus Jesus never
came into existence like Jeremiah did
like you and me did. Jesus always
existed
eternally existed. That's why he's God
according to the Bible. But then you
have to okay let's let's go for the sake
of the argument that he existed before
that. What is your proof that he existed
before that? I mean you have of course
proved that according to the old
testament it says god was there he
created something but where do you have
I mean let's say the the passage from
revelation which you cited from the new
testament is true what proof do you have
I mean this is a statement of course it
is a vision
>> you ask me about you as you ask me about
what where I get this from in the Bible
does the bible teach this and so I'm
showing you that if you want to reject
the bible you can but you can't say the
bible doesn't teach this right
>> the new testament Yes.
>> Okay. So, all right.
>> But I'm asking you where where is your
>> go ahead. Sorry.
>> Okay. Sorry. I mean I'm asking you okay
let's say for the sake of the argument
it it is true you that it is meant in
this way in which you said it is meant.
So in revelation Jesus says he is
pre-existing and internally existing. So
where is your proof that Jesus
pre-existed? You know what I mean? You
have to you have this statement. You
have given me the explanation. Now give
me the proof.
>> What do what do you mean I mean the
proof?
>> The proof that Jesus
you don't have to repeat your statement.
But what is what is like what is the
proof that you're that you're asking
for? Cuz you you you acknowledge that
Jesus says it.
>> So he does make the claim that he has
eternally existed. So now you're asking
me to prove that he eternally existed.
No, I'm I'm what I'm asking for is you
said he eternally existed. So I am
saying in a vision.
>> Is there something wrong with God
talking in a vision?
>> I mean there can also be uh
interpretations. I mean of course there
are visions in the Bible.
>> Are there are there just just please do
revelations come in visions?
>> According to what I understood yes I
mean we can disagree. So no, I I agree
with you. Revelation comes through
visions and other ways as well, but one
of those ways is visions. Another is
dreams and so on and so forth. So you
saying, "Oh, it's a vision though," is a
nonpoint, right? That's that like that
shouldn't even be brought up between me
and you. So let's let's not waste time.
What is the what are you asking me
about? Cuz Jesus made the claim that he
existed eternally. What's the problem
now?
>> Okay. I Okay, I try to explain it once
more. The what I'm asking is Jesus made
this claim and Jews said okay he is
pre-existing according to the claim he
made and what you understood from
revelation. Now I'm saying is okay if
this passage is understood uh it should
be understood in the way you explained
then give me a proof from the old
testament that Jesus pre-existed. You
know what I mean? I mean if he is
almighty god.
>> Oh that he was there.
>> Yes. Yes. This is what I'm saying. Sorry
for being sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
There was so much uh barrier in the
language. So
>> it's okay. So you wanted evidence. You
wanted an evidence that Jesus was there
in the Old Testament.
>> Yes. That's why what I'm asking.
>> That's all you That's all you had.
>> That's all you had to ask. Okay.
>> So what I'm going to show you for being
wasting your time.
>> Yeah.
>> It's okay, man. We just communication
and we just try with patience. We get
clarity. Okay. So this is Jude. This is
the New Testament and it's referring to
something in the Old Testament. Okay?
And I'll show you the Old Testament
passages talking about, right? So,
according to the Old Testament, the
Torah, God saved the people from the
land of Egypt. Right.
>> Oh, yeah. From the land of Egypt.
>> Mhm. And specifically, he does it
through an agent called the angel of the
Lord. You heard that phrase before?
>> Yes. Yes. The angel of the Lord is the
one who comes and
uh comes in the pillar of fire and is in
the cloud protecting the Israelites from
Pharaoh's troops that are trying to
chase them up until they get to the sea
before Moses splits it. So the angel of
the Lord, the angel of his presence, the
angel of his face is the one who's there
saving and delivering Israel out of
Egypt. Right?
>> That's in the Old Testament. That's
you'll find that in Exodus. You'll find
that mentioned in Deuteronomy. You also
find that mentioned in like uh I think
it's Malachi and Hosea and stuff, other
prophets when they think back on it.
Okay. So, we go to Jude. This is the New
Testament. Jude is referring back to
that. And this is what he says. Now, I
want to remind you, this is verse 5. Now
I want to remind you although you once
fully knew it that Jesus who saved a
people out of the land of Egypt
afterward destroyed those who did not
believe i.e. Pharaoh's armies. So Jude
here who's a brother of Jesus is saying
that that was Jesus in the Old Testament
the angel of the Lord who was saving
Israel and destroying Pharaoh's armies.
That was Jesus.
>> Just a sec. Okay. Just a second. This
was in the New Testament. Yes. The book.
>> Yeah. Jude Jude 1. There's only one
chapter.
>> Jude. Yes. I have it here. Just a
second.
>> Verse 5.
>> Jude 1 verse verse 5. He said, "Yes."
>> Yep. Verse five.
>> So he he you say he's talking about
Jesus. That's the second.
>> That's right. That's the truth.
>> Okay.
>> That's the truth.
>> Yeah. I have this passage. But I mean,
thank you for Yeah. Can you hear me?
>> You see it?
>> Yes, I have. Thank you very much.
>> Awesome. So, you see how he says that
that was Jesus in the Old Testament
saving the people of Egypt? I mean, uh,
saving the people of Israel out of
Egypt.
>> That's right. But now, imagine I I'm not
a Christian. So, you believe that? I
mean, this statement was made after
Jesus came. Yes.
>> You asked me for you asked me for the
proof in the Bible to show you that he
was
>> from the Old Testament. I I specifically
said Old Testament.
>> Yeah, I know. So, I showed you where
this I showed you where this mentions
Jesus in the Old Testament. That was
Jesus in the Old Testament doing that.
The Bible explicitly says it. That was
your proof.
>> I mean, then you could also have brought
Isaiah 53 and other things or you could
say, "Oh, this was meant Jesus."
>> That's true. I could do that because
Yeah, that's right.
>> I could point to I could point to all of
these passages that is about Jesus in
the Old Testament. I could have pointed
to prophecies about Jesus in the Old
Testament, but I didn't want to show you
a prophecy. I wanted to show you a
recounting where somebody, a Jew, is
remembering back what God did in the
past and said, "Hey, actually, that was
Jesus who did that."
>> Okay. I mean, I I don't I don't want to
waste your time, so I will look up this
passage, go through uh go through it. Um
I think at this stage I would say okay
for me I have to look into it because I
mean now you have made your point that
uh there is somebody referring to Jesus
there that this is Jesus and not
somebody else. Of course for me the
question would then be okay if it's if
Jesus is meant it says I think in the
Hebrew it's Malik so it's an angel of
course then the question would arise
okay there are
>> the the angel appears a lot of time is
it then always Jesus or not
every every time just to give you an a
heads up answer while you go into your
research the answer is yes whenever you
see the angel of the lord mentioned in
the old testament the angel of the lord
is always Jesus that's popping up.
>> So you mean angel of the Lord is always
Jesus.
>> The angel of the Lord. The angel of the
Lord is always Jesus. When you see the
phrase the Malik Yahweh, the angel ha
Malik Yahweh, the angel of the Lord,
that's always Jesus.
>> Yes. Okay, then let's see. Thank you. I
mean, I
>> welcome. Yeah. Yeah. Make your point.
Yes.
>> No, no, no. I was I was saying you're
welcome.
>> Okay. Okay. So, thank you for having the
opportunity. It was nice talking to you.
>> Same.
>> And wish you a good evening.
>> You too, bro. You too. Talk to you soon.